hi I'm Erik Bosse and with Avengers
infinity war a little over a week away
as we pull apart each and every one of
these trailers posters and TV spots like
a loner child you really should keep an
eye on one of the biggest mysteries is
where the hell is Hawkeye you know it's
gotta be great for Hawkeye to be missed
so much even he felt a little out of
place in these movies she's flying we're
fighting an army of robots and I have a
bow and arrow none of this makes sense
but it is pretty odd for all this promo
material to feature pretty much every
other Marvel character and for one of
the six founding Avengers to be left out
with the actor's name not even on the
poster yeah yeah I know ant-man isn't
there either but at least that guy has
his own movie coming out this summer
remember yeah don't forget about that so
I am gonna go into some theories about
hawkeye's whereabouts and spoiler
warning in case any of this predictin
ends up being right now let us start
with how the filmmakers have responded
to Hawkeye's absence back in March the
Russo brothers said that after the
events of Captain America Civil War
Hawkeye has gone quote on his own
journey
more recently the directors have said
that his absence is all tied into the
story and to be patient and they didn't
forget Jeremy Renner but they said this
we we just cooked up a story for him
that that is a little bit of a long play
not a not a short play long play so uh
how long of a play are we talking here
Hamlet long oh it's a it's a sports play
not a theater play got first theory on
what this could mean
Hawkeye dies immediately Dori we can
debunk this one pretty easily yes it is
true that in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics when Thanos famously snaps his
fingers to wipe out half the universe
Hawkeye is among the heroes in Avengers
HQ who fade away it really freaks cap
out but of course in the convoluted plot
of that comic storyline time gets reset
a day earlier rewinding all of that
assist destructions no it's everyone's
ok but but but we do know that jeremy
renner will remain part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if not in infinity
war then definitely infinity War part 2
set photos have confirmed this in the
case that infinity war features Hawkeye
dying and coming back at the end of the
movies somehow I think it would be too
sneaky and cruel for the Russos to
explain his absence with all this talk
of journeys and long plays unless unless
less that long play involves Doctor
Strange who's in the time stone too
set the timeline allowing infinity War
part 1 to kill off basically everyone
and then part 2 to rewind the clock back
to past Avengers movies now I'm saying
too much to go check out our other video
for all of our info on our time travel
theories but those set photos I
mentioned bring us to our second theory
for hot guys whereabouts Hawkeye is
becoming Ronin Ronin is a name from
Marvel Comics that several characters go
under including Clint Barton
it's a masterless samurai a lone warrior
in those set photos Jeremy Renner's leg
appeared to show a costume that's very
similar to the Ronin look he also has a
mohawk style haircut and tattoos
covering his arm and other pictures of
the set look like a Japanese setting
adding fuel to this speculation
so perhaps part of Hawkeye's absence
involves a relocation of Japan where he
might dawn the ronin mantle he could be
going there on a mission or a safe haven
to relocate his family after his brush
with the law and civil war or a personal
exile to find himself we all need to
breather sometimes now I'll get to the
next theory in just a second but first I
want to quickly thank audible for
sponsoring this video
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audiobooks that you can
listen to anywhere while you're doing
anything traveling community and cooking
and cleaning hiding for the world while
you practice your oak tree just check
out audible.com slash new rock stars now
he follows regularly you'll know we were
really into ready player one which is an
audiobook I actually listen to from
audible in the audiobook is really the
best way to catch up with the source
material for the recent movie actor Wil
Wheaton does the narration for it he's a
friend of the author and a character
within the world of a story so it's just
so meta it's so wonderful start your own
30 day trial and your first audiobook is
free just go to audible.com slash new
rock stars or text new rockstars to 500
500 or get click on the link in the
description below guys you can do it
with audiobooks ok back to my next
theory Hawkeye is searching for Captain
Marvel in another interview Joe Russo
revealed that Captain Marvel will be
part of the movie a recent set photo for
the movie Captain Marvel showed SHIELD
agent
Maria Hill in Nick Fury without eyepatch
that origin film will be set in the
1990s presumably before fury got that
famous injury but an infinity war
perhaps the journey that Hawkeye is on
is a mission assigned by Fury to track
down Carol Danvers to get her to join
the fight against Thanos the image of
jeremy renner introducing brie Larson as
Captain Marvel sounds like something we
could see in a post-credits scene a
member of the old guard on his way out
passing the torch to a member of the
next generation no just something to
think about moving on to another theory
for Hawkeye Hawkeye is training a
replacement this one comes to us from
our buddy saying basher always thinking
that one the idea is that since Clint's
main story arc for the past two movies
has been his want to retire perhaps the
reason he's been gone is that he's out
recruiting and training a protege to
take over the Hawkeye mantle from him if
the MCU decides to go this way a really
good pick would be Kate Bishop in my
opinion her Hawkeye was a member of the
Young Avengers and she has a role in the
Civil War event but really ever since
the reveal of Hawkeye's wife Laura and
their kids in age of Ultron any
storyline with Clinton Barton cannot
ignore his family and that brings us to
our final theory and warning it's pretty
dark Hawkeye's family dies in the
ultimate comics Hawkeye joins a
celebrity superhero team called The
Ultimates one of whom betrays him by
leading a black ops team into his home
to murder him his wife and their three
kids in the bloody aftermath of this
crime scene Clint Barton's body is
missing now this old really dark solo
narrative is probably too much as a
subplot for an already packed infinity
war movie but the shocker of Barton
losing his family this way would be
tragic and yeah shocking enough that I
could see the Russo brothers tiptoeing
around it while they're promoting the
movie it also could be what they're
hinting at when they're talking about
his own journey in a long play
ultimately it sounds like Hawkeye
storyline whatever it is will happen off
screen away from the main narrative of
infinity war aside from that post credit
scene idea that I brought up I could see
a version of infinity war that totally
doesn't need Hawkeye in it and instead
saves his involvement for an even larger
event of infinity War part 2 everyone is
on the chopping block guys they've got
to have one Avenger as a designated
survivor right but a question for you
guys if you could swap out any character
currently in infinity war for Hawkeye
who would it be now the answer is yeah
that's right no one right Hawkeye is
awesome but all of these other
characters are looser
more interesting but if you want you
could just say like Falcon or Wang and
I'll pretend to believe you comment down
below with your thoughts or tweet me
directly idea of austin pablo new rock
stars on twitter for updates on our
videos like this video share it around
and subscribe to new rock stars work all
of our coverage on the nvidia infinity
war guys we're so close I can smell
those stones smell like oh they smell
like death of course okay thanks for
watching bye
[Music]